it's Friday night and that means it's
time for Friday Follies oh yeah Michael
Moore believes that only one candidate
could be Trump Burger King unveils new
meatless patties and Joe Biden's big
political rescue joining us with all the
details Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor Raymond we missed you last
week I know you had fun in France and
liberal provocateur Michael Moore now he
feels like he has the person who can
beat Trump
yeah well amazingly Laura he floated
this idea after one of the Democratic
debates this week watch the only way to
remove Trump is to crush Trump who's the
street fighter that can crush Trump and
frankly I think there's a person that
could do this if the election were held
today there is one person that would
crush drama and she hasn't announced yet
and her last name rhymes with Obama
Michelle Obama
Lorrimer ation this is desperation writ
large okay rather than making a case for
one of the Democrats actually running
for the office more ignores them all and
he reaches into Never Land from Michelle
Obama Michelle is not participating in
the race Michael as she's has said
repeatedly would you ever run for
elected office and you always say I have
never wanted to be a politician nothing
has changed in me to make me want to run
for elected office I want to serve I
want to do work I want to be out there
but there are so many ways to make an
impact politics is just not my thing
Laura she is again and again said she's
not doing this look you and I covered
the early days of the Obama
administration when Desiree Rogers came
out and said we're not just a political
movement here we are a brand the Obama
brand man Michelle Obama more than
anybody else has cultivated and curated
that brand now selling more than 10
million books worldwide she is not about
to jeopardize that Laura to run for
political office
she'll be politically vetted and have to
stand for policies and issues that will
inevitably divide and dissipate
I just tried this with pushing Oprah
after that award speech she gave you no
George Clooney they pushed George
Clooney at one point in time they even
floated Rapinoe oh yeah they pushed her
for five seconds I mean I mean
Evangelina Jolie couldn't she run I mean
honestly they pushed every possible
celebrity and Michelle is a global
celebrity brand all right what is he
this is Fahrenheit 2020 so from Queen
Michelle to Burger King the fast food
giant is unveiling a meatless whopper
this model or it's called the impossible
whopper and the patties are made by a
company called impossible foods of soy
protein coconut oil and genetically
manipulated soy and yeast which allows
it to bleed now customers claim they
can't tell the difference this is a cow
no cow like a whopper
okay it's like a beeper it's made of
[ __ ] beef right here you see that
it's beef we swear it's not beef that's
impossible it tasted just like a whopper
should taste why 7000 Burger Kings will
offer this impossible whopper Laura but
if you wanted a whopper why would you
get a Sawyer nobody wants this a soy
patty with grill marks I don't know why
people would want this no but that when
you said and I actually I think I got a
little sick in my throat just that when
you said to make it bleed yes you
squeeze it and red comes out I don't
like the genetically modified anything
well I've got some other quick quick
facts here it's a dollar more there's
more protein in the beef and this thing
has more saturated fat this impossible
whopper and more sodium than beef I mean
sounds like it's 10 times more it's a
you know an ounce there's a reason
there's a reason chick-fil-a is the fast
food
America's favorite fast food chain now
Laura this week I don't know if you saw
this to rescue of several beached whales
in Florida now the Coast Guard and
locals ban
together to pull this off but there was
a political rescue in the media that was
perhaps even more daring this week ah
looking at Viton tonight he actually had
a strong performance tonight he showed
something he didn't show last time which
is fight he had a very strong night last
night Joe Biden came prepared to defend
his record this time around and to go on
offense got into the fight his team will
be happy that he showed up that he
responded that he fired back amazingly
Laura this was the Joe Biden they were
talking about with the whole you know
the whole asking the immune system we
free further support the the the the
ability to buy into the Obamacare plan
the bills that the president that excuse
me the future president here that that
that the senator is talking about go to
Joe 303 300
in this fight make it stop that is so
poor bad I mean I I felt bad for him he
was trying to get them to go to a text
you know the text 303 oh he actually
sent them to a website that supports
Pete Buddha judge
it's a wonder he found the Fox Theater
Laura and didn't end up in Hannity show
that I think that's unfair I think he
actually had a pretty good night but he
did have I thought he was pretty
I mean look they're all coming at him he
he was the only one that didn't look bat
blank crazy okay
as far as I can tell he's the only one
who has any common touch well III think
I think when you look at this when you
look at this it's and stand back the
fact that so many on the Left are
looking for other solutions and not
spending any time making the case or
building up the men and women standing
on the stage contending for the office
that tells you something but if Joe
Biden is the front-runner this almost
German I just almost sneezed on national
TV oh my god
I'm allergic to Friday Follies I'm
telling you I'm just not you like your
next it's great to have you back
Raymond was another cute Paris the last
week with the little people